[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition
in this video we're breaking down the
old guard on netflix
the charlize thorough movie has just
dropped today and there's a lot to
unpack from it
throughout this video we'll be going
through everything you need to know
about the film
including its ending the source material
that inspired it
and where the franchise could be going
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
yet then i highly recommend that you
check out now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and as
always please drop a thumbs up as it
massively helps us out
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
the old god
okay so the old guard is based on the
comic book of the same name by greg
rocker and leonardo fernandez
the 2017 release gained a lot of
critical acclaim at the time
and it's been a quick turn around taking
this from comic to comic book movie in
a matter of years it's easy to see why
too
and the source material stands head and
shoulders above a lot of other releases
due to its unique concept like the
original work
the movie follows a group of immortal
mercenaries that travel the world
completing jobs
they're basically like the true nut from
dr sleep but not a bunch of chumps
that i absolutely hate now we as humans
sort of gain purpose in life
by knowing that time is of the essence
however when it comes to the characters
in the old god
they live pretty lonely lives due to
merely existing through the ages
and knowing countless people that have
died they are clearly tired of it
in some ways it's like they just want
things to end
whilst also being attached to their
lives this is exemplified by the line
that opens the film
in which andromach of scythia or rather
andy played by charlize theron
says that she's exhausted andy dates all
the way back to ancient greece
and two of the other members were on
opposing sides of the crusades
these actually ended up as lovers and
are called nikki and joe
whilst the final immortal is called
booker booker was a deserter during the
napoleonic war
and this kind of plays into his arc now
there are some caveats to their
immortality
and rocker added a neat little twist to
their abilities
whilst they can heal from pretty much
any wound
they can also die and they themselves
are unaware of whether the next thing
that happens to them
will be the one thing that finally ends
their life so
they still fight for every moment and
that's why
we don't really see them wedding into
things without a strategy
this uncertainty adds tension to the
work and thus
makes for a gripping read they also
dream of one another which we'll discuss
in just a bit
but yeah there's a lot going on and
that's pretty much the basic premise
and the movie follows in the footsteps
of the original work
with us predominantly following andy and
three other members of the undying
warriors
as they become targets the group have
been lying low for some time
keeping incognito as much as possible
however
they've drawn the attention of people
who wish to possess their gifts
namely a man called copley copley is an
ex-cia agent
whose wife died of als and this drove
his wish to try and discover the secrets
to immortality
so that others wouldn't have to suffer
like she did copley hires them for a
rescue mission
in order to save some school children
that were kidnapped by militia
upon arriving there though the warriors
discover it to set up
walk into a kill box and are pretty much
wiped out by the swat team there
however due to their abilities they
survive and strike back
using the weapons that they've collected
over the aeons such as an
axe sword and dagger it's a brilliant
way to kick start the movie
another situation is something that
you've probably seen a
million times in hitman movies before
because of the unique story
of the immortals it adds something to
the plot that we haven't really seen
since highlander
it's here that we're introduced to nile
who recently discovered that she's
immortal
and the character becomes the audience's
eyes and ears as we learn about the
group
now the old god is actually a nickname
for the oldest active duty regiment in
the us army
we learned that each of the members
served in a war at some point
and due to their immortality the
nickname stuck copley wants to make
their abilities a commodity
by selling their secrets to a scientist
named merrick that is obsessed with
prolonging his life and others
it's it's dudley i'll get you dudley
however as we learn
immortality is just as much a curse as
it is a gift
now i was very excited for this film and
unfortunately
i'm not sure if it completely delivers
upon the promise of the graphic novel
but andy the characters on the whole
just seem
slightly mundane and for people that
have had long and rich
lives they seem rather i don't know
uninteresting
they sort of don't really do their page
counterparts justice
and yet for me the film felt a bit meh
at certain points
this idea of living through wars
constant loss
and healing from every injury has of
course been discussed with wolverine and
the x-men franchise
and i feel like it was done to much
greater effect there
i know they have to kind of explain how
things work for an audience that isn't
aware of what's going on
but as someone who already knew i did
find the opening rather slow paced
and if you have an idea of how things
are you will likely feel that nile is
just
learning of the group simply so the
story can go through the motions early
on
that's not to say it's bad i just felt
that when compared to its comic book
counterpart
it was the slow god instead of the old
god
yeah my puns they were never their best
now thuron
as always brings a game and the oscar
winner is clearly one of the most
capable actors out there
she can pretty much do it all and after
atomic blonde
really stepped into the role of an
action star with ease she definitely
carries the movie and makes for a great
mentor to nile
we also learn about the past that
they've faced and how difficult it is to
be different in a world that wants
everyone to be the same
it's torturous seeing some of the things
that they've ended up going through
such as an iron maiden that led to one
member called quinn
spending centuries drowning over and
over andy and quinn were close
and she promised to find the character
one day but never managed to
which led to the latter facing centuries
of pain that eventually drove her insane
now i'll talk about how quinn reappears
at the end as there's stuff we need to
discuss
but it's definitely something to bear in
mind overall the group have lost
everyone they've ever loved
and is definitely painless throughout
their memories these aspects are far
more interesting than the main plot
itself to me
and i wish they'd spent more time in
these moments rather than the present
which is basically just a run-and-gun
storyline
either way you can really start to see
the downside of immortality through this
and the state of guilt misery and fear
that they constantly live in
this comes to boiling point when copley
launches an attack on the group
and they kidnap nikki and joe which
forces the others to go after them
now we see first-hand through merrick
that if you're immortal
people inevitably want to take it from
you and this leads to you being hunted
which means the life you have becomes
bad so there was no point of being
immortal in the first place
the undying are the ones left behind
rather than the lucky ones that get to
die
and it's definitely the film's most
interesting aspect
after the attack by copley andy realizes
that she's no longer healing
and you also see how copley realizes
he's made a deal with the devil
merrick is willing to subject them to
all kinds of suffering
in order to get what he wants and yeah
he's really not a good dude
i'll get you dudley now nile questions
whether she wants this life or not
and leaves to spend time with her family
while she still can
upon leaving she realizes that booker
double-crossed them due to giving both
her and
andy an empty gun booker has of course
lived in misery for centuries
and he's realized that if they can
discover how to make people immortal
they can also end his life andy is shot
and she doesn't heal
but she's still bundled up with booker
and taken to the lab
merrick knocks out copley and niles
stumbles across him
it's here that we learn that though andy
believes she doesn't really have a
purpose in life
that the countless number of people that
she's saved over the centuries
has had massive ramifications on the
world this ties into the saying that
the one that saves one life saves the
entire world
and though andy didn't intentionally
select these people the fact that she
saved so many
showed her actions eventually led to
things being good
even though she viewed her actions as
being bad and the world is getting worse
nile heads out to rescue the group and
using her immortality she's able to
fight her way through merrick's forces
she frees the group which leads to a
finale that has an all-out shootout with
merrick's forces
i'll bloody get you dudley now i love
how andy uses a fire axe instead of her
regular one
and there's some amazing bits of combat
as annie goes out swinging
in what could be her last dance it's a
mortal combat
with a lot of fatalities and it
definitely picks up the pace for the
final act
and he realizes that upon being faced
with death that things are actually
worth fighting for
and as merrick arrives nile aims a gun
at her to distract him so that she can
attack him with the axe
allowing nile to grab him and throw them
both out of a skyscraper window
it's an awesome way to kill off that
bloody dudley and it saves andy's life
the group decide what to do with booker
and nile has a tough choice to make
she can either make it look like she was
killed in action to save her parents the
pain that comes with being immortal
or go and see them and make the most of
the time she has left with them
they ostracize booker from the group for
100 years which he will spend alone
and annie says her goodbyes to him
knowing that she likely won't live long
enough to see him back with the group
they reunite at copley's house and see
the collages put together of all the
positive ways that they benefited
humanity over time
it finally gives them purpose and makes
them realize that they can no longer lie
low
and have to tackle things head on and
change the world in a positive way
by stepping into the light instead of
hiding in the shadows
copley will cover up what they do but no
doubt they will finally make a change
for
the better now andy is of course in
danger
due to no longer being immortal however
i think that because of merrick's work
they will find a way to stabilize her
condition once more
and if there is another film i do
believe that the subplot will
center around her taking her abilities
back the movie sort of has an extra
scene in it
in which we see booker six months later
in paris drinking himself to death
well well not death but he's greeted by
quinn
who we see has escaped from the iron
maiden now the movie adapts the old gods
storyline
opening fire which started its five
issue run in 2017.
following this the creative team planned
a trilogy off the back of it
with the second storyline being called
force multiplied
the film changes things slightly as in
the original run
quinn was called noriko but i think they
switched this up so that fans of the
comics would
have some surprises for the movie in the
source material noriko and andy will
love
us and they spend time sailing around
the world on a ship
however noriko was swept away by the
ocean and she spent centuries
drowning and resurrecting over and over
again which is similar to what we see in
the film
the character wants revenge for andy
never coming to save her
another latter just wants to talk things
through noriko wants blood
this leads to a big battle that spills
over publicly
and ends up drawing the attention of the
fbi now as of making this video
the fifth and final issue has not been
released and it's due to come out on the
15th of july
so if you have read it then let me know
in the comments below what you thought
of it
the creative team behind the work have
said they're planning a trilogy
so there's definitely a lot of things to
look forward to in regards to the
franchise if a sequel goes ahead
now before we get into the rest of the
video i just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the mcu
infinity saga box set to one random
subscriber
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the film in the comment section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of july and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
price
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
okay now what did i think of the movie
well i found it a bit inconsistent with
the first hour being very bland
before the second half really delivered
on what i wanted to see
because of this the film was a bit
unbalanced however
charlize is brilliant in it as are the
action and flashback scenes
it really does discuss a lot of elements
that i'd want to see in a film about
immortals
but i don't think it completely knocks
it out of the park in comparison to
other comic book movies out right now
it falls slightly short and even out of
the few that have been released this
year
i think it probably ranks below them all
and that's including bloodshot
saying that though it is definitely
worth watching there are a lot of
interesting avenues that they can take
the franchise in the future
it's not one i'm gonna rush back to
watch but overall i'd say i enjoyed it
more than i didn't
and thus it scores a seven out of ten
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the old god so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up if you want something
else to watch that's netflix related
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of dark which is going to be
linked at the end
we go over the crazy ending of the show
and everything we took from it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavyspoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with the channel
and hopefully we see over there very
soon and with all that out of the way
i've been definition
you being the best i'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you